a police chase in chicago's west side
after reports of gunfire
the officer shouts at 13-year-old adam
toledo
the officer calls for an ambulance but
it's too late
the teenager who was latino died in the
alley from a fatal gunshot wound to the
chest
the police released a photo of a gun
found in the alley
but adam's family say this wasn't a
reason to shoot him
those videos speak for themselves
adam during his last second of life
did not have a gun in his hand
their lawyer says although adam was shot
dead on the 29th of march
his mother didn't find out until two
days later
they had a lot of options but not kill
him
they couldn't shoot his head his leg his
arm
up in the air i don't know but i killed
my baby
the officer who shot adam has been
placed on administrative leave while an
inquiry is carried out
and police have arrested a man they say
was with adam and fired the shots that
drew them to the alley that night
chicago's mayor was visibly emotional as
she spoke about the toll of violence in
her city
i have sat in too many circles watching
these young people who are beautiful and
magnificent
but traumatized by the violence that
they experience
every day
every day as residents of our city
as the u.s waits for the verdict in the
trial of the former police officer
charged with murdering george floyd
relations between the police and many
communities are at rock bottom
and the death of a 13 year old boy at
the hands of the police
is not going to help improve things
becky kochel
sky news